[Music]
straight ahead
on law and crime daily federal
authorities released their findings in
the helicopter crash
that killed kobe bryant his daughter
gianna and seven others
the probable cause of this accident was
the pilot's decision
to continue flight under visual flight
rules
into instrument meteorological
conditions paris hilton shares her story
of abuse
and trauma why the celebrity is trying
to use her influence to bring change
but i cannot go to sleep at night
knowing that there are children that are
enduring
the same abuse that i and so many others
went through
our case is based on cold
hard facts opening statements in the
trump impeachment trial
our experts weigh in on the arguments
presented by both sides
denounce the violence of the
rioters plus an inside look at the
witness names expected to be called
during the trial of the former officer
accused of murdering george floyd
law and crime daily covering court cases
from coast to coast
welcome everyone to law and crime daily
i'm brian buckmeyer along with terry
austin
a little more than a year after a
helicopter crash killed kobe bryant his
daughter
and seven other people the ntsb says the
crash was preventable
and jeanette lieby is here with the
agency's findings
yeah brian the investigators believe
that decisions that the pilot made
in flight led to this crash and they
also said that they do not believe that
kobe bryant
pressured the pilot to fly that morning
an accident is something that is
unforeseen
unpredictable if you will unfortunately
this wasn't a sad statement from the
chairman of the ntsb about the crash
that killed kobe bryant
his daughter gianna and seven others
including the pilot
investigators said when the sikorsky
s76b
took off there was two and a half miles
of visibility
even with the hindsight that we have of
the weather conditions
and knowing what was available to the
pilot we don't see that this
the weather conditions were such that
should have necessarily affected the
initiation of the flight
but investigators found conditions
worsened during the flight and pilot
erizobian
flew through the clouds and became
disoriented experiencing the liens where
a pilot believes he's flying straight
when he's actually in a turn the
helicopter crashed into a hillside
investigators said zobian didn't follow
his training and had little time using
instruments in the helicopter he didn't
follow
any of the recommended
mitigations for entering
instrument meteorological conditions
ordered properly
once he had entered them configured the
aircraft
by slowing down by starting a climb by
activating the autopilot none of that
happened
and the ntsb board found that zobian
that day
likely had some type of self-induced
pressure to complete this mission they
said it's like a comfort
a common phenomenon that happens among
pilots they want to finish the job they
want to get through it they said he
should have actually changed course had
another plan
and actually landed that plane the nts
board also
said they believe there were some
deficiencies for island helicopters the
company that employed the pilot
but they didn't believe that those were
deliberate they said they were more out
of um
ignorance rather than any type of malice
brian
thanks for the update in the findings
and jeanette joining us today to break
down the tragic crash is retired swat
officer and law and crime analyst lisa
lockwood and terry austin
lisa surprisingly to me at least
helicopters like this
don't have a black box so what goes into
an investigation like this in order to
get the type of report we just heard
it's going to be completely dependent on
the communication with the air traffic
controller
and the last communication with the
flight air traffic controller was
i'm nearly breaking through the clouds
now
so knowing full well it was very dense
and shortly after that last
communication is when the crash had
occurred
so they are completely dependent on that
they did have a way to know
that he didn't ascend or descend in the
proper fashion as well
so black boxes very important and air
ambulances are equipped with this
they have that in their in their
aircraft
in helicopters in order to maintain and
to go through
terrible conditions so i'm not certain
why
the it's not a requirement in any kind
of
aircraft um especially helicopters
because we know that those crashes
crashes are a lot more frequent without
having
that um it's actually called a terrain
awareness warning system
so i'm hoping that the faa goes ahead
and actually approves having that device
in all
all of helicopters going forward yeah
let's hope for that and
a change in the policies terry the pilot
the person the report is saying
is at fault passed away in the crash so
what does that mean
for the brian's lawsuit you know vanessa
bryant's civil suit it's a wrongful
death action
it will survive even though the ntsb
said that the pilot was at fault she's
suing and she's saying the owners
and the operators they should have
properly trained him they should have
properly supervised him
so essentially what she's saying is
regardless of what the pilot did
during that operation the owner and the
operators are responsible because they
should have shown him
how to get out of that type of situation
exactly now anjanet
some of the board members questioned
whether there should have been two
pilots on board right
yeah they did question that quite a bit
but they said it was perfectly legal to
just have one pilot
with this type of aircraft but they said
there are other companies that have had
this type of aircraft and had two pilots
they say that enables a pilot who might
be having some trouble to
you know bounce what they're seeing and
feeling off of another pilot and maybe
get some feedback to change course
all right so maybe this tragedy will see
a second pilot in the cockpit
cockpit sorry and a black box as well to
hope hopefully this doesn't happen in
the future thank you all for
contributing
and now to an update on the so-called
doomsday cult couple saga
law and crimes jesse weber has a new
report that's raising more questions
than
answers tammy dabel that's a name that
should sound familiar to many of our
viewers here on law and crime
she's the deceased former wife of chad
dabell the man criminally charged
alongside his current wife
lori valo dabel for their alleged roles
in the discovery of lori's dead children
tammy died strangely just two weeks
before chad married laurie
and chad originally told investigators
that tammy died in her sleep
but authorities found that to be a bit
suspicious so they exhumed her body in
december
2019 now it has been announced that an
autopsy has been completed
but results are sealed as part of an
ongoing investigation
also the prosecutor in fremont county
where chad and tammy lived at the time
of her death
has now taken over the investigation
from the state ag's office
and what's interesting to note is that
investigators didn't say anything about
whether tammy's death was a result of
foul play
which raises questions about what could
happen next
for long crime i'm jesse webber
thanks jesse always a crazy twist make
sure to check him out on prime crime
still ahead on law and crime daily paris
hilton shares her horrifying story of
suffering abuse
when she was a teen but first we take
you inside the senate chambers for the
trump impeachment trial
our expert analysis next
[Music]
four hours worth of opening statements
kicked off the senate impeachment trial
of former president donald trump
that's a high crime and misdemeanor if
that's not an impeachable offense
then there is no such thing house
impeachment manager jamie raskin
laying out his case beginning with clips
from the january 6th stop the steel
rally
turn riot we won this election and we
won it by a landslide this was not a
close election
and after this we're going to walk down
and i'll be there with you
we're going to walk down we're going to
walk down
to the capitol
[Applause]
[Music]
we are going to the capitol where our
problems are
then raskin got personal telling how his
daughter
went with him to watch the counting of
the electoral college votes
days after his son's death our new
chaplain got up and said a prayer for us
and we were told to put our gas masks on
and then there was a sound i will never
forget the sound
of pounding on the door like a battering
ram
the kids hiding under the desk placing
what they thought were their final
texts and whispered phone calls to say
their goodbyes
they thought they were going to die
raskin wrapped up by reminding the
senate
of the fallen and wounded officers
officers ended up with
head damage and brain damage people's
eyes were
gouged we cannot have presidents
inciting and mobilizing mob violence
against
our government and our institutions
because they refuse to accept the will
of the people under the constitution of
the united states
then trump's lead impeachment attorney
bruce castor presented the defense
caster previously served as a district
attorney outside of philadelphia
this trial is about
is about trading liberty for the
security from the mob
honestly no it can't be we can't be
thinking about that
we can't possibly be suggesting that
we punish people for political speech in
this country
and if people go and commit lawless acts
as a result of
their beliefs and they cross the line
they should be locked up caster cutting
to the chase
saying the 14th amendment doesn't apply
we are
really here because the majority in the
house of representatives
does not want to face donald trump as a
political rival
in the future that's the real reason
we're here and that's why they have to
get over the jurisdictional hurdle which
they can't get over
but that's why they have to get over
that in order to get to the part of the
constitution that allows removal
so that's the nobody says it that
plainly
but unfortunately i have a way of
speaking that way
the trial is expected to continue at
noon on wednesday with each side having
16 hours to present their case
after senators will have the opportunity
to ask their own questions
witnesses could be called next week
it'll be up to the senators who serve as
the jury to vote to convict
or acquit trump here to break down
former president trump's second
impeachment trial is lisa lockwood and
terry austin
lisa unlike the last impeachment trial a
lot of what the senate will be bringing
or
will even see is video evidence and
social media posts
from those who stormed the capitol and
were there on january 6th
talk to us about investigating a case so
heavily focused
on video footage well it's a it's a huge
win it's a win for the fbi it's
it's a win for getting the people
convicted who actually
breached police barricades who assaulted
police officers
who stormed the capitol who stole
property
the list goes on and the thing about
this is they freely
and willingly posted publicly on social
media platforms
the fbi was able to put together a very
comprehensive list
of photographs pictures and they were
able to identify people who are actually
involved
they're still looking for some members
and they're looking at flight records
they're doing all of their due diligence
after they received all the information
with photographs and created their fbi
uh most wanted list for this particular
instance
so this is a huge win for the american
people
in order to put these people who
actually created all of this havoc
and and entered an establishment that's
so sacred to
the united states now terry
unconstitutional
you can't remove a former president from
office
they've already been voted out first
amendment his speech is protected
these are the arguments we're likely to
hear do you see them working
during this impeachment process well i
think that the house managers made the
stronger argument their form and their
substance lisa mentioned the video
the fact that they were just opposing
the actions of the individuals to the
words of trump i think was very
impactful and they made great
arguments there's no question that from
a precedent standpoint
you can impeach someone who's left
office so i
absolutely think their arguments are
going to prevail at the end of the day
now let me just create myself removal
process but at the end of the day it's a
numbers game will 17 republicans
vote against donald trump or former
president donald trump i apologize
we'll have to watch to see coming up on
law on crime daily why prosecutors in
the george floyd case want to tack on
another charge to the ex-cops
plus pirates hilton goes before the utah
senate
her call to denounce childhood views and
bring change in the troubled teen
industry
after the break
[Music]
celebrity paris hilton took to utah
state senate to advocate for the
regulation of the troubled teen industry
after she was abused when she was 16
years old
for the past 20 years i've had a
recurring nightmare
where i'm kidnapped in the middle of the
night by two strangers
strip searched and locked in a facility
i wish i could tell you that this
haunting nightmare was just a dream
but it is not when i was 16
two transporters woke me up in the
middle of the night with handcuffs
they asked me if i wanted to go the easy
way or the hard way
they carried me out of my home as i
screamed at the top of my lungs from my
parents help
i was taken to the airport and separated
from everything
and everyone i knew and loved provo
canyon school
was my final stop i was given close with
the number on the tag
i was no longer paris i was only number
one to seven i was verbally mentally
and physically abused on a daily basis i
was cut off from the outside world
and stripped of all of my human rights i
was not allowed to be myself
hold my own opinions or even speak
without a diagnosis i was forced to
consume medication
that made me feel numb and exhausted i
didn't breathe fresh air or see the
sunlight for 11 months
there was zero privacy every time i
would use the bathroom or take a shower
it was monitored at 16 years old
as a child i felt their piercing eyes
staring at my naked body
i was just a kid and felt violated every
single day
back for analysis is retired swat
officer lisa lockwood and co-host terry
austin
lisa you've investigated cases like this
you've helped
bring justice for young women who have
gone through this when you hear paris
hilton's words
what does that mean to you yeah
knowingly that she was
she was forced into that environment
we've heard of these programs before
scared straight teen boot camps this is
in essence a way to eradicate
poor behavior or bad conduct or people
who have gotten arrested or addicted to
drugs and that sort of thing
but what she endured was far beyond the
scope of
any means to help correct her behavior
whatever
it was physical verbal and mental abuse
all came together she was not allowed to
go outside for 11 months no fresh air
whatsoever and as
she mentioned strip search on a regular
basis
so fortunately they have brought light
to this and
they will be making changes i believe
because of
her and a lot of other celebrities
coming forward and discussing
their um their kind of false
imprisonment
for something that had to do with a
mental disorder
now terry similar question do you think
that these words could create change in
utah if not
maybe the entire country absolutely
whenever you have a spokesperson like
paris hilton coming to a committee
hearing like that
it does sway the individuals who are
listening to her words
you know she's talking about the mental
and physical abuse and the bill is going
to require
more government oversight of these
residential treatment centers
and it's going to require that they
document when they use restraints so i
think it was helpful
i do as well when we come back breaking
down the first trial in the george floyd
case
the witness list the jury instructions
derek shovin's defense
all ahead
the first trial of a former minneapolis
police officer for the death of george
floyd
is set to begin in just a month and both
sides are preparing their cases
derek showman is facing charges of
second-degree unintentional murder and
second-degree manslaughter
chauvin's defense won their bid to drop
the charge of third degree manslaughter
well prosecutors are asking a judge to
reinstate it after an appeals court
upheld the same charge for former
minneapolis cop muhammad noor
prosecutors also submitted a witness
list of more than 300 names
including the three other officers
charged in floyd's murder they're slated
to go to trial separately this summer
the defense is naming more than 200 of
their own witnesses including hennepin
county prosecutors removed from the case
by a judge
the case is being tried by the minnesota
attorney general keith ellison's office
a long process toward justice the
defense also submitted a list of 37
requests
including not allowing sheldon to be
referred to as a defendant at trial
not allowing floyd to be referred to as
a victim or likening his death to jesus
and limiting testimony about medical
examinations to only those performed by
the county coroner
remember floyd's family hired dr michael
baden to conduct an independent
examination
the cause of death
in my opinion is asphyxia
due to compression of the neck
which can interfere with blood flow
and oxygen going to the brain those
findings differ from hennepin county
medical examiner
who ruled floyd's death was a homicide
caused by a cardiopulmonary arrest while
being restrained by law enforcement
the officers killed him based on
a knee to his neck for almost nine
minutes
and two knees on his back compressing
his lungs
the ambulance was his hearse
governor tim walls is authorizing the
minnesota national guard to help provide
security during the trial
a move that could cost millions jury
selection is scheduled to begin on march
8th
opening statements are expected march
29th
here one last time to tell you what
could be coming from the final motions
in the george floyd trial
are lisa lockwood and terry austin lisa
you've testified in countless cases are
these requests
normal or do you think they are unique
due to the magnitude of this case
and why it is an exorbitant number we
looked at 300 from the prosecution side
and 200 from the
the defense side you're going to be
looking at
former and employees who are going to be
look at character
looking at character witnesses as well
as the co-defendants
and the people who are there actually
filming the video so
the list goes on and on that they want
to be able to have a perspective from
every area former bad acts we talked
about that allowing that
information coming forward only a one
one would be allowed
for chauvin and you're not able going to
be able to see
anything that happened prior to with
george floyd's arrests
and him resisting in the past so i have
never seen an amount this
this high as far as witnesses but this
case is extremely
important for change for change in law
enforcement
now terry i looked at some of these and
even by my standards i know i follow a
lot of motions before trial but
i'm questioning some of them now for you
are these proper
ridiculous or strategic what do you make
of these uh requests by both sides
you know i think it's interesting this
is a high profile
case so i do think there will be a lot
of strategic
maneuvering here and all of the you know
people involved want to make sure
that they sort out any issues prior to
trial so
while it might seem ludicrous i think it
makes sense to try to resolve you know
whether or not you're going to call the
defendant defend it
all right thank you both and thank you
for joining us here at long crime daily
we'll see you next time as we discuss
justice in america
[Music]
[Music]
you